You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步路。我们省了多少钱？够了。足够让我们迷路了！或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. It's hard to make good decisions if you don't understand numbers. Whether it's choosing a health insurance plan, deciding whether to buy a house,
希尔顿促销活动现已开启。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可享 8 折优惠，获得你期待的住宿体验。当你想要的是节省开支，而不是意外惊喜时。你住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为你提供理想住宿。如果你不懂数字，就很难做出正确的决定。无论是选择健康保险计划，还是决定是否买房，
or weighing the risks and benefits of taking a new medication, many important life decisions hinge on understanding numbers, statistics, or probability. Today we're going to talk to a psychologist who studies how people process numbers, perceive risk, and make decisions about what it means to be numerate and why numeracy matters. We'll discuss how common innumeracy is and how it affects people's health, financial security, and other life outcomes. We'll also talk about how you can improve your confidence and ability with numbers, even if you had many years past your last high school math class. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
或者权衡服用新药的风险和益处，许多重要的人生决策都取决于对数字、统计数据或概率的理解。今天，我们将采访一位心理学家，她研究人们如何处理数字、感知风险以及做出决策，探讨什么是“识数能力”（numeracy）以及为什么它很重要。我们将讨论“不识数”（innumeracy）现象有多普遍，以及它如何影响人们的健康、财务安全和其他生活结果。我们还将讨论即使你已经离开高中数学课堂多年，如何提高自己对数字的信心和能力。欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。
My guest today is Dr. Ellen Peters, Director of the Center for Science Communication Research at the University of Oregon, and a professor in the Department of Psychology and the School of Journalism and Communication. She studies how people understand numerical information, perceive risk, and make decisions. She also studies how doctors, public officials, and other communicators can present numerical information in a way that helps people understand it better. Dr. Peters is an APA fellow and a fellow of the American. and Association for the Advancement of Science. She's the author of hundreds of peer-reviewed academic papers and of the 2020 book, Inumeracy in the Wild, misunderstanding and misusing numbers. Dr. Peters, thank you for joining me today. Kim, it's a pleasure to be here. Thanks for inviting me.
我今天的嘉宾是俄勒冈大学科学传播研究中心主任、心理学系及新闻与传播学院教授艾伦·彼得斯（Dr. Ellen Peters）博士。她研究人们如何理解数字信息、感知风险并做出决策。她还研究医生、政府官员和其他传播者如何以有助于人们更好地理解的方式呈现数字信息。彼得斯博士是美国心理学会（APA）会士，也是美国科学促进会（AAAS）会士。她撰写了数百篇同行评审的学术论文，并著有 2020 年出版的《野外的不识数：误解和滥用数字》（Innumeracy in the Wild: Misunderstanding and Misusing Numbers）一书。彼得斯博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。金，很高兴来到这里。谢谢你的邀请。
Let's start, as we often do on this podcast with a definition. What does it mean to be numerate or innumerate? How do you measure people's numeracy? So we call it objective numeracy. because it has to do with how well people answer problems in a math test. So objective numeracy is the ability to understand and use basic probability in mathematical concepts. And so it's kind of like numeracy is to numbers, like literacy is to words. Now, what are some of the most common ways that math and numbers come up in everyday life? And how well do people understand these things? Oh, gosh. So numbers come up in all kinds of ways. So I often work with people in health. I work with physicians or folks in public health, and it comes up when it comes to prescription drugs you take, for example. And even in a
我们像往常一样，从定义开始。什么是“识数”或“不识数”？你如何衡量人们的识数能力？我们称之为“客观识数能力”，因为它与人们在数学测试中回答问题的准确度有关。因此，客观识数能力是指理解和使用基本概率和数学概念的能力。这有点像识字能力之于文字，识数能力之于数字。那么，数学和数字在日常生活中出现的最常见方式有哪些？人们对这些事物的理解程度如何？哦，天哪。数字以各种方式出现。我经常与健康领域的人合作。我与医生或公共卫生领域的人士共事，例如，当你服用处方药时，数字就会出现。甚至在
couple of different ways. So just with prescription drugs alone, numbers come up when it comes to how likely you are to benefit from the drug or how likely you are to suffer from side effects. But numbers also come up when it comes to you figuring out when do I need to order my next round of medication. And so there's just kind of numbers all over the place. All kinds of other hazards too. We've been looking a bit lately at wildfire risks, for example, and other kinds of natural hazards. And the numeric information involved helps people better understand how likely might I end up in a situation like this. And how do they figure that out? I mean, what kind of data do you get to make that determination when we're talking about, say, wildfires?
几个不同的方面。仅就处方药而言，当你考虑从药物中获益的可能性或遭受副作用的可能性时，数字就会出现。但当你需要弄清楚何时需要订购下一批药物时，数字也会出现。所以数字无处不在。还有各种各样的其他风险。例如，我们最近一直在研究野火风险以及其他类型的自然灾害。所涉及的数字信息有助于人们更好地理解我陷入这种情况的可能性有多大。他们是如何弄清楚这一点的呢？我的意思是，当我们谈论野火时，你会得到什么样的数据来做出这种判断？
So with wildfires, it's often more, it's often more visual. So it's a map. But sometimes that map will also come with a likelihood of how likely is my area, for example, to be at wildfire risk. So I know, for example, that there's an area of town that's quite near my daughter's house that's at a higher risk of wildfire than some of the rest of our city. So we can find out numerically, well, how likely is the risk at her house versus some other part of town? How common is enumeracy among U.S. adults and are there differences based on sex or other demographics? Yeah. So enumeracy is fairly common. It turns out that about a third of working age adults in the United States perform at what's considered the lowest proficiency level in numeracy. And so in some ways you can actually consider this about a third of working age adults functionally enumerate.
对于野火，它通常更直观。它是一张地图。但有时这张地图也会附带一个可能性，例如，我所在的地区发生野火风险的可能性有多大。所以我知道，例如，我女儿家附近有一个区域，其野火风险比我们城市的其他部分要高。因此，我们可以从数字上找出她家与城市其他部分相比，风险的可能性有多大。美国成年人中“不识数”现象有多普遍？基于性别或其他人口统计学特征是否存在差异？是的。不识数现象相当普遍。事实证明，美国约三分之一的劳动年龄成年人的识数能力处于被认为最低的水平。因此，在某种程度上，你可以认为这三分之一的劳动年龄成年人在功能上是不识数的。
They can't do things, for example, or likely would not be able to do things, for example, like calculating the difference in percentages of patients who survive one treatment compared to another. They don't have the math skills that are necessary to understand that kind of information. And it's not that they can't do anything with numbers. These are often very smart people. But when it comes to numbers, they just don't have a lot of abilities. So they can do things, they can do sort of simple processes with numbers like counting and sorting the numbers or doing very simple arithmetic, like simple addition, for example. And it's not just a question of whether you can do it in your head, right?
例如，他们无法完成，或者很可能无法完成计算不同治疗方案患者存活率百分比差异之类的事情。他们不具备理解此类信息所需的数学技能。这并不是说他们对数字一窍不通。这些人通常非常聪明。但当涉及到数字时，他们确实缺乏很多能力。所以他们可以做一些事情，他们可以对数字进行简单的处理，比如计数和分类，或者进行非常简单的算术，比如简单的加法。而且这不仅仅是一个你是否能在脑海中完成的问题，对吧？
I mean, even if you need a piece of paper, it's just that you understand the relationships and you can make calculation. Yeah, exactly. So when we give a numeracy test to people, for example, a lot of people do the math problems in their head, but they don't have to. They could actually pull out a piece of paper. and try to figure it out. And it is the case, you asked this a minute ago, and I kind of missed the question, but it is the case that some systematic differences in numeracy exist across the population. So you see things like women tend to be less numerate than men, controlling for other characteristics of them. But there are other things, too. We actually tend to become less numerate as we age. So as our minds slow down, our abilities with numeric processes that we haven't memorized, because if you've memorized, them, you've stored them in long-term memory, but if it's a new information that you have to
我的意思是，即使你需要一张纸，关键在于你理解其中的关系并能进行计算。是的，完全正确。例如，当我们对人们进行识数能力测试时，很多人在脑海中完成数学题，但他们不必这样做。他们实际上可以拿出一张纸来计算。而且，你刚才问过这个问题，我当时没回答好，但确实存在一些系统性的差异。例如，在控制了其他特征后，女性往往比男性识数能力稍弱。但还有其他因素。随着年龄增长，我们的识数能力往往会下降。因此，随着思维变慢，我们对那些尚未内化为长期记忆的数字处理能力就会下降；如果是需要处理的新信息，
actually process, that's the kind of numeracy that tends to decline as we age. Less numerate people are also more likely to be lower in income, to have minority status, and of course to have lower education. That's actually one of the reasons I really value studying numeracy, because understanding numeracy and understanding how people process numbers also ends up being associated with understanding how we understand inequities that exist across our society. So how does numeracy compare with literacy? Are they on the same level? Are we as illiterate as we are enumerate in this country? Yeah, it's a good question. So it's a little hard to compare them. But the comparisons that I've seen are that we are more enumerate than we are illiterate.
那正是随着年龄增长往往会下降的识数能力。识数能力较弱的人也更有可能收入较低、属于少数群体，当然受教育程度也较低。这实际上是我非常重视研究识数能力的原因之一，因为理解识数能力以及人们如何处理数字，最终也与理解我们社会中存在的不平等现象有关。那么识数能力与识字能力相比如何？它们处于同一水平吗？在这个国家，我们是否像不识数一样不识字？是的，这是一个好问题。所以很难将它们进行比较。但我所看到的比较结果是，我们不识数的情况比不识字的情况更严重。
And you can almost even see that just in how people talk about it. People are, people are quite embarrassed to be illiterate. They don't want to admit it, but everybody's willing to admit that they're enumerate. Like, I'm just bad at math and anyone could, and it's sort of an indication that enumeracy perhaps is more common, but it's also an indication that people might not understand how important it is and how important it is to be able to process numbers well in our information-rich society. How do we compare with other countries, like other European countries or Asian or African countries, are they as enumerate as we are in this country? I mean, one-third is a pretty high number.
你甚至可以从人们谈论它的方式中看出来。人们对不识字感到非常尴尬。他们不想承认，但每个人都愿意承认自己不识数。比如，“我就是不擅长数学”，这似乎表明不识数可能更普遍，但也表明人们可能并不了解它的重要性，以及在我们这个信息丰富的社会中，能够很好地处理数字有多么重要。我们与其他国家相比如何，比如其他欧洲国家、亚洲或非洲国家，他们像我们国家一样不识数吗？我的意思是，三分之一是一个相当高的数字。
Yeah, it is a pretty high number. So the last data that I know about are back in 2020. And there's more recent data available, but I don't know what the cross-country comparisons are. But back in 2020, we tended to be on the less numerate side. So if you look just at the proportion of people, for example, who are in that very low, those very low numeracy levels. At that point in time, the U.S. had about 29% of people in that very low numeracy levels. Countries like Italy were similar.
是的，这是一个相当高的数字。我所知道的最新数据是在 2020 年。虽然有更新的数据，但我不知道跨国比较的情况。但在 2020 年，我们往往处于识数能力较弱的一方。如果你只看那些处于极低识数水平的人口比例，当时美国约有 29% 的人处于极低识数水平。意大利等国家的情况类似。
They had 32% in that least numerate. Spain had 31%. But then some other countries, and remember, we're comparing to the U.S. at 29%. Japan had only 8% of people in that least numerate. Finland, only 13%. Same with the Czech Republic, as well as the Netherlands. And so there actually are quite a few countries who are more numerate than the United States is.
他们有 32% 的人处于识数能力最低水平。西班牙有 31%。但其他一些国家——记住，我们是在与美国 29% 的比例进行比较——日本只有 8% 的人处于识数能力最低水平。芬兰只有 13%。捷克共和国和荷兰也是如此。因此，实际上确实有不少国家的识数能力比美国强。
And is this a failure of our educational system, or is there something else going on? Personally, I think it is about our education system. When I talked about the proportion of least numerous people in countries, we're talking about the people who are at the very lowest levels of math ability. You can also look at the other side. And we have a lot of extremely numerate people in the United States.
这是我们教育系统的失败，还是有其他原因？我个人认为这与我们的教育系统有关。当我谈到各国识数能力最弱的人口比例时，我们谈论的是数学能力处于最低水平的人。你也可以看看另一面。我们在美国有很多识数能力极强的人。
But we also have these big disparities of numeracy in the U.S. We also have big disparities in our educational system. And so to me, what it looks like is that our educational systems are failing portions of our population who end up being less numerate. What are some of the most common errors that people make when they're trying to understand numerical information? Not spending enough time on it. Just simply not looking at the numbers for very long, not trying to transform a number from one way of looking at it to another. And let me give you an example of that. So one of the things that we study, in my field of judgment and decision making is something called framing effects. So a framing effect is like 90% of people will survive if they get this treatment or in the alternative frame, 10% of people
但我们在美国也存在巨大的识数能力差距。我们的教育系统也存在巨大的差距。所以在我看来，这看起来像是我们的教育系统辜负了我们人口中最终变得识数能力较弱的那部分人。人们在试图理解数字信息时最常犯的错误有哪些？没有花足够的时间。只是简单地没有看太久的数字，没有试图将一个数字从一种观察方式转换为另一种方式。让我举个例子。在我的判断和决策领域，我们研究的一件事叫做“框架效应”。所以框架效应就像是：如果接受这种治疗，90% 的人会存活；或者在另一种框架下，10% 的人
will perish if they get this treatment. And they are logically equivalent. 90% surviving versus 10% dying is the exact same number. But what happens is to be able to understand that, you actually have to do that math. You actually have to take the 90% survival and say, oh, No, that means the 10% of the people die. But a lot of people, even if they can do that math, they don't do it. They just don't tend to look at the numbers and think about them. They don't, people who are less numerate in particular, just don't have the same habits with numbers that people who are highly numerate do.
如果接受这种治疗会死亡。它们在逻辑上是等价的。90% 的存活率与 10% 的死亡率是完全相同的数字。但问题是，为了理解这一点，你实际上必须进行数学运算。你实际上必须拿 90% 的存活率说，哦，不，这意味着 10% 的人会死亡。但很多人，即使他们能做这种数学题，他们也不会去做。他们往往只是不看数字，也不去思考它们。特别是那些识数能力较弱的人，他们就是没有识数能力强的人那种处理数字的习惯。
Someone who is highly numerate will look at the 90% survival. And more or less, in fact, I would bet that you more or less automatically transformed it. The minute I said 90% survival, you thought 10% die. Not everybody does. Those kind of math operations aren't as easily accessible to them, and they're a little bit harder, and so they're just simply more likely to walk away from them. And so I think those are some of the biggest errors that people make. They don't put in the time, and it is a little more effort for them. And so as a result, they end up using other information that's not as helpful. So if they're given, if they're told about a treatment where they have a 10% chance of dying, they're going to feel much worse. that if they're told that they would have a 90% chance of survival, even though it's the same treatment. Right. We tend to latch on to the negative. We tend to latch onto the negative, but we also tend to latch onto information in the form it's given and without changing it. And by changing information, you get more meaningful information.
识数能力强的人会看 90% 的存活率。事实上，我敢打赌，你几乎会自动转换它。我一说 90% 的存活率，你就想到了 10% 的死亡率。并非每个人都会这样做。那些数学运算对他们来说并不容易获得，而且稍微困难一些，所以他们只是更容易放弃。所以我认为这些是人们犯下的最大错误。他们没有投入时间，这对他们来说确实需要多一点努力。结果，他们最终使用了其他不那么有用的信息。因此，如果告诉他们某种治疗有 10% 的死亡率，他们会感觉糟糕得多，即使告诉他们有 90% 的存活率，尽管这是同一种治疗。没错。我们倾向于抓住负面信息。我们倾向于抓住负面信息，但我们也倾向于以给定的形式抓住信息，而不去改变它。通过改变信息，你可以获得更有意义的信息。
You get to understand the more complex set of information that's in front of you. It's not just that you're most likely to survive, but you might actually die. And by doing that transformation, you understand that in a deeper way. What about the concept of probability? How well do people understand that? I mean, I've heard people say, well, you know, everything's 50-50, either will or it won't. And that's not how probability works. Yeah, that is so interesting.
你可以理解摆在你面前的一组更复杂的信息。不仅仅是你最有可能存活，而且你实际上可能会死亡。通过进行这种转换，你可以更深入地理解这一点。那么概率的概念呢？人们理解得如何？我的意思是，我听过人们说，嗯，你知道，一切都是 50-50，要么会发生，要么不会。但概率不是那样运作的。是的，这太有趣了。
And it's actually a really interesting problem in medical decision-making. Because to an individual person, that is true. It's going to happen to me or it's not going to happen to me. But if you take a step back and you look at a population of people that's similar to that person, then you can get to predicted likelihood. So the predicted likelihood that a medication will help you, for example. And people are not very good with probabilities. It's one of the types of math that we tend to have the most problems with.
这实际上是医疗决策中一个非常有趣的问题。因为对于个人来说，这是事实。它要么发生在我身上，要么不会发生在我身上。但如果你退后一步，看看与那个人相似的人群，那么你就可以得到预测的可能性。例如，药物对你有帮助的预测可能性。人们对概率不太擅长。这是我们往往最容易出问题的数学类型之一。
And in fact, most objective numeracy tests deal with probabilistic kinds of information because they tend to be harder and probabilities are, are important in a lot of everyday life events. You've done research that's looked at how numeracy affects people's health outcomes, their financial outcomes, and other aspects of life. What are the consequences in a day-to-day area of innumeracy? Yeah, so we actually kind of already started one of those. So one of the ways that numeracy seems to have impact on people's lives
事实上，大多数客观识数能力测试都涉及概率类信息，因为它们往往更难，而且概率在许多日常生活中都很重要。你做过研究，观察识数能力如何影响人们的健康结果、财务结果和生活的其他方面。不识数在日常生活中有什么后果？是的，我们实际上已经开始讨论其中之一了。所以识数能力似乎对人们生活产生影响的方式之一
has to do with their ability to make good decisions. even though everybody might get the same information, they might be given the exact same choice options. People have those different habits that we started talking about. For someone who's less numerate, numbers are harder, as we were talking about. And what research ends up showing is that their decisions end up being more vulnerable to their own emotional reactions, to how information is framed, to compelling stories that they're given or images that they're shown. And what this means when they're judging and deciding is that they will be more vulnerable to the framing effects we talked about. Or they'll be more vulnerable to using other cognitive shortcuts, heuristic shortcuts that people take.
与他们做出正确决策的能力有关。即使每个人可能获得相同的信息，他们也可能被给予完全相同的选择方案。人们有我们开始讨论的那些不同的习惯。对于识数能力较弱的人来说，数字更难，正如我们所讨论的那样。研究最终表明，他们的决策最终更容易受到自身情绪反应、信息呈现方式、他们被告知的引人入胜的故事或展示给他们的图像的影响。当他们在判断和决策时，这意味着他们更容易受到我们讨论过的框架效应的影响。或者他们更容易受到使用其他认知捷径、启发式捷径的影响。
They also may end up being, and in fact research shows that they'll end up being more susceptible just to how they're feeling in the moment, like their mood states. And then ultimately, studies show that they neglect numbers more, even if they think they're using them, they'll end up. up neglecting numbers more. The people who are highly numerate have a whole different set of habits. So they're more likely to seek out numbers. They're more likely to think longer about them, to transform numbers like we were talking about and do different calculations. They're even more likely to compare numbers and do just other kinds of operations with numbers that help them see a number that has meaning rather than see a number that's dry and feels irrelevant to them. So that's kind of the first way that numeracy has an impact.
他们最终也可能，事实上研究表明他们最终更容易受到当下感受的影响，比如他们的情绪状态。最终，研究表明他们更忽视数字，即使他们认为自己在利用数字，他们最终也会更忽视数字。识数能力强的人有一套完全不同的习惯。他们更有可能寻找数字。他们更有可能花更长时间思考它们，转换数字，就像我们讨论的那样，并进行不同的计算。他们甚至更有可能比较数字并对数字进行其他类型的运算，这有助于他们看到有意义的数字，而不是看到枯燥且感觉与他们无关的数字。这就是识数能力产生影响的第一种方式。
And that has an impact on sort of everyday life. It's not just that math has to do with STEM education. Understanding and being able to use math has to do with the quality of your everyday life. And that then, as you started to mention, that then shows up in some of the consequences that people end up with. And my lab is not the only one that studies this. One study that we've done in our lab shows that people who are highly numerate make more money. And so for each individual problem, extra problem that a highly numerate person solved, they made $4,000 more in annual income after controlling for a whole slew of other demographics. People who are more numerate also end up being much wealthier. People on top of that, there's only one study that I know of on this, but people who are more numerate seem to be more likely to be employed rather than unemployed compared to people who are less numerate.
这对日常生活产生影响。数学不仅仅与 STEM 教育有关。理解并能够使用数学与你的日常生活质量有关。正如你开始提到的，这随后会出现在人们最终面临的一些后果中。我的实验室并不是唯一研究这个问题的。我们实验室进行的一项研究表明，识数能力强的人赚更多的钱。因此，对于每一个额外的问题，一个识数能力强的人解决的问题，在控制了其他一系列人口统计学特征后，他们的年收入增加了 4,000 美元。识数能力强的人最终也变得富有得多。最重要的是，据我所知，只有一项关于此的研究，但与识数能力较弱的人相比，识数能力强的人似乎更有可能就业而不是失业。
And then you get to health gaps, and there have been a whole bunch of different health gaps that have been studied. I'll mention just a couple. People who are less numerate are 40% more likely to have at least one chronic disease, and they also take 20% more prescription drugs, according to this study. And all of this is while having less ability to follow complex health regimens that involve numbers, because they're having difficulty with numbers. Now, this is a correlation, right? We're not talking causation in this instance.
然后你就会遇到健康差距，已经研究了许多不同的健康差距。我只提几个。根据这项研究，识数能力较弱的人患至少一种慢性病的可能性高出 40%，而且他们服用的处方药也多出 20%。所有这些都是在他们无法遵循涉及数字的复杂健康方案的情况下发生的，因为他们在处理数字方面有困难。现在，这是一种相关性，对吧？在这种情况下，我们谈论的不是因果关系。
For the most part, we're talking correlation. So most of the studies have been done with correlational data. A lot of them control for other non-numeric aspects of intelligence and for other demographics like education, but there's still correlational data. You're absolutely right about that. There have been a few studies that have looked at experimentally manipulating numeracy. And they've found those have found causal effects on risk perceptions. different kinds of behaviors, financial literacy.
在大多数情况下，我们谈论的是相关性。因此，大多数研究都是用相关性数据完成的。其中许多研究控制了其他非数字方面的智力以及教育等其他人口统计学特征，但它们仍然是相关性数据。你说的完全正确。有一些研究观察了对识数能力的实验性操纵。他们发现这些研究对风险感知、不同类型的行为、金融素养产生了因果影响。
So there's a few studies out there, but it's actually difficult to make a large impact on adult numeracy unless you put them through a very, very long, like a math course, unless you put them through sort of a long training course. We're going to take a short break, and when we return, we'll talk with Dr. Peters about whether our increasing reliance on technology is making us more or less numerate. It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose GoogleFi wireless.
所以有一些研究存在，但除非你让他们参加非常、非常长的课程，比如数学课，除非你让他们参加某种长期的培训课程，否则很难对成年人的识数能力产生重大影响。我们要休息一下，回来后，我们将与彼得斯博士讨论我们对技术的日益依赖是否使我们变得更识数或更不识数。现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务扩展很快。为了保持花蜜流动，我需要一个拥有顶级优先数据速度的电话套餐。这就是我选择 GoogleFi 无线服务的原因。
My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now, that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore GoogleFi wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees. GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill four-burner gas grill on special buy for only $199.
即使在蜂巢嗡嗡作响时，我的连接依然强劲。此外，无限流量套餐每月 35 美元起。这真是一个不会持续太久的优惠。立即探索 GoogleFi 无线套餐。另加税费和政府费用。GoogleFi 无线服务在网络使用高峰期不受数据流量降级限制。你的夏天从家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。是时候用 Nextgrill 四炉头燃气烤架开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。
And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. Loss supplies last. Pricing valid May 14th or May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. Is technology making us more enumerate or is it helping us be less enumerate? I'm asking just like in a day-to-day fashion, like you go to the grocery store and if the cashier doesn't see what the change is on the register, they have no idea how to make change anymore. I mean, I used to have to do that calculation in my head when I was a checker many years ago.
整个季节都可以用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅招待客人，仅需 49 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止。价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日。仅限美国，适用排除条款。详情请参阅 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。技术是让我们变得更识数，还是在帮助我们变得不那么识数？我问的是日常生活中，比如你去杂货店，如果收银员在收银机上看不到找零是多少，他们就不知道如何找零了。我的意思是，我多年前做收银员时，必须在脑海中进行那种计算。
So I'm just astonished that people can't do these things. Yeah, I actually had a well-known psychologist actually told me a story once. He was at a checkout counter. Let's say the bill was 75 cents. How did that work? Basically, he was giving her money so that she would give him back a full dollar. And she couldn't do that on the fly, unfortunately. And so is technology helping or hurting?
所以我很惊讶人们竟然做不到这些事情。是的，实际上有一位著名的心理学家曾经给我讲过一个故事。他在收银台。假设账单是 75 美分。那是怎么回事？基本上，他给了她钱，这样她就会找回他一整美元。不幸的是，她无法当场做到这一点。那么技术是在帮助还是在伤害？
I think it's both. So I think it's hurting in the sense that you're talking about. People are kind of losing that ability to make calculations on the fly. And that kind of thing, I suspect, will make people more vulnerable, even more vulnerable to framing effects, for example. Because if you don't do that change, that switch from 90% survival to 10% dying, then you're not going to have complete information. Or you're not going to be able to figure things out at the cashier, all of those kinds
我认为两者都有。所以我认为它在你说的那种意义上是有害的。人们正在失去那种当场进行计算的能力。而且我怀疑，那种事情会使人们更容易受到影响，甚至更容易受到框架效应的影响。因为如果你不进行那种改变，那种从 90% 存活率到 10% 死亡率的转换，那么你就不会拥有完整的信息。或者你将无法在收银台弄清楚事情，所有那些情况
of situations. I think technology helps in other ways, though. So technology can be used to help support people. If they're not going to understand the numbers, the technology can be that backup system so they don't get cheated or so that they better know what the meaning of information is. So, for example, in medical decision making, a lot of researchers and folks in the medical field have worked on decision aids. And those decision aids are very explicitly intended to help people better understand the numbers that underlie one cancer screening option versus a decision aids. another, for example, or one treatment option versus another. And so the technology also supports. So I'd say it's kind of a two-edged sword. You've done some research that's looked at people's
我认为技术在其他方面有所帮助。所以技术可以用来帮助支持人们。如果他们不理解数字，技术可以成为那个备份系统，这样他们就不会被欺骗，或者这样他们能更好地了解信息的含义。例如，在医疗决策中，许多研究人员和医疗领域的人士致力于决策辅助工具。这些决策辅助工具非常明确地旨在帮助人们更好地理解某种癌症筛查选项背后的数字，或者决策辅助工具。另一个，例如，或一种治疗方案与另一种治疗方案。所以技术也提供了支持。所以我说这是一种双刃剑。你做过一些研究，观察了人们的
actual skill and their confidence with numbers and how those two things interact. What have you found? Yeah. So I just found this fascinating. We had started to study objective numeracy kind of early in my career. And then along the way, I came across this idea of numeric confidence. and realized that it's almost equally important to objective numeracy. So we did a set of two studies in one paper that came out in PNAS. And they're both correlational studies,
实际技能和他们对数字的信心，以及这两者是如何相互作用的。你发现了什么？是的。我发现这太迷人了。我在职业生涯早期就开始研究客观识数能力。然后在此过程中，我偶然发现了“数字信心”这个概念，并意识到它几乎与客观识数能力同样重要。所以我们在发表在《美国国家科学院院刊》（PNAS）上的一篇论文中进行了一组两项研究。它们都是相关性研究，
but what we did, one of them was in a financial domain and one was in a medical domain. And so we had access to people's self-reported financial outcomes, whether they had ever carried more than $5,000 in credit card debt, for example, whether they had ever defaulted on their mortgage, whether they had retirement savings. So some of the outcomes were positive and some were negative. We transformed it so that everything was about positive outcomes. In other words, so you have not defaulted on your mortgage is a positive outcome.
但我们所做的是，其中一项是在金融领域，另一项是在医疗领域。因此，我们能够获得人们自我报告的财务结果，例如他们是否曾经背负超过 5,000 美元的信用卡债务，他们是否曾经拖欠抵押贷款，他们是否有退休储蓄。所以有些结果是积极的，有些是消极的。我们对其进行了转换，使一切都关于积极的结果。换句话说，你没有拖欠抵押贷款是一个积极的结果。
And then we measured their objective numeracy and we measured their numeric confidence. And what we found, and you can think about it in sort of two different ways. One thing that we found was that when people are high in numeric confidence, their objective numeracy matters. So if they're high in numeric confidence and they have high objective numeracy, they do really well in financial outcomes. But if they're high in numeric confidence and they're actually very low in ability, which does happen, those are the people who do the worst. And so when you're high in confidence, it can help you if you have the ability and it helps you to flourish. But if you're low in ability, what we think happens is that they go ahead and take charge of their own decisions because they're
然后我们测量了他们的客观识数能力，并测量了他们的数字信心。我们发现，你可以从两种不同的方式来思考它。我们发现的一件事是，当人们具有很高的数字信心时，他们的客观识数能力就很重要。所以如果他们有很高的数字信心并且有很高的客观识数能力，他们在财务结果上表现得非常好。但如果他们有很高的数字信心，而实际上能力非常低，这种情况确实会发生，这些人表现得最差。所以当你信心很高时，如果你有能力，它会帮助你，它会帮助你蓬勃发展。但如果你能力很低，我们认为发生的情况是，他们继续负责自己的决策，因为他们
confident. They can do it. But while they're confident they can do it, they may be making mistakes because they don't have the ability. And they may not be catching those mistakes, again, because they don't have the ability. And they may not be asking for help again because they think they have that ability. But then if you look at the people who are low in confidence, I found this fascinating. Objective ability almost made no difference to their financial outcomes, whether they are high or low in objective ability. When they had low confidence, it's like they just didn't step up to the plate. They just didn't try to use their numeric abilities. And because of that, their financial outcomes were about the same, whether they're low or high inability. Those were self-reported
有信心。他们能做到。但当他们有信心能做到时，他们可能会因为没有能力而犯错。而且他们可能不会捕捉到这些错误，同样是因为他们没有能力。而且他们可能不会再次寻求帮助，因为他们认为自己有那种能力。但如果你看看那些信心不足的人，我发现这太迷人了。客观能力对他们的财务结果几乎没有影响，无论他们的客观能力是高还是低。当他们信心不足时，就像他们根本没有挺身而出一样。他们只是没有尝试使用他们的数字能力。正因为如此，他们的财务结果大致相同，无论他们的能力是低还是高。那些是自我报告的
financial outcomes. And so we're also really interested in, can we get to a more real outcome? Not that those aren't a real outcome, but they're self-reported. But I was working with a few rheumatologists at the time. This is a type of doctor who treats people with things like arthritis, But they also treat people who have lupus. And lupus is a very serious autoimmune disease that actually involves a lot of numeric processing because they have to figure out how to take medication. They have to understand the risks and benefits of their medication. They have to get to doctor's appointment.
财务结果。所以我们也对能否获得更真实的结果非常感兴趣。并不是说那些不是真实的结果，但它们是自我报告的。但我当时正在与几位风湿病学家合作。这是一种治疗关节炎等疾病的医生，但他们也治疗患有狼疮的人。狼疮是一种非常严重的自身免疫性疾病，实际上涉及大量的数字处理，因为他们必须弄清楚如何服用药物。他们必须了解药物的风险和益处。他们必须去看医生。
There's just kind of a whole bunch of little numeric tasks that they have to do on an everyday basis. And so we're interested in taking a look at the same hypothesis with them. And in particular, because if they gave us a little, permission, we would have access into their medical records, and we could see how the physician thought they were doing in terms of how active their lupus was. And so we were with two rheumatologists helping out, we actually were able to access a sample of lupus patients who very kindly agreed to do our measures of numeracy and numeric confidence, and they allowed us, very kindly allowed us
他们每天必须完成一大堆小的数字任务。所以我们有兴趣与他们一起研究同样的假设。特别是，因为如果他们给我们一点许可，我们就可以进入他们的医疗记录，我们可以看到医生认为他们在狼疮活跃度方面表现如何。所以我们与两位风湿病学家合作提供帮助，我们实际上能够获得一个狼疮患者样本，他们非常友好地同意进行我们的识数能力和数字信心测量，并且他们非常友好地允许我们
access into their medical records. And we found the same result. The people who were low in confidence, their ability didn't make a difference. But if they were very high in numeric confidence, if they were high in ability, they did great. Their health was doing great. But if they were high in confidence, but they were low in ability, those are the people who are actually doing the worst. Their disease activity was the highest, and they're at most risk for long-term damage. What can people do to improve their numeracy? There's a number of things people can do. The first one has to do with what we were just talking about, that that interesting relationship between objective ability and numeric confidence, the first thing people can do is figure out who they are as a
访问他们的医疗记录。我们发现了同样的结果。那些信心不足的人，他们的能力没有产生影响。但如果他们有很高的数字信心，如果他们能力很高，他们表现得很好。他们的健康状况很好。但如果他们信心很高，但能力很低，这些人实际上表现得最差。他们的疾病活动度最高，而且他们面临长期损害的风险最大。人们可以做些什么来提高他们的识数能力？人们可以做很多事情。第一件事与我们刚才讨论的有关，即客观能力与数字信心之间那种有趣的关系，人们可以做的第一件事是弄清楚他们作为一个
math person because believing you're not skilled when you really are can hurt you because you're not doing as well. You're not taking advantage of the skills that you actually have. And so people need to be open to the possibility that they might be good at math so that they're more likely to use numbers in these everyday kinds of situations that we're talking about. But on the other hand, believing that you're skilled at math, when you really don't have those kind of math skills, that can really hurt, that can really hurt you. So encouraging people to figure out where they are, like, who am I as a math person? How can I match my level of numeric confidence with the level of ability that I actually have can really help? It means that you'll ask for help if you need it, and maybe you'll try harder
数学人是谁，因为相信自己不熟练而实际上很熟练会伤害你，因为你表现得不够好。你没有利用你实际拥有的技能。所以人们需要对他们可能擅长数学的可能性持开放态度，这样他们就更有可能在这些我们正在讨论的日常情况下使用数字。但另一方面，相信自己擅长数学，而实际上并没有那种数学技能，那真的会伤害你，那真的会伤害你。所以鼓励人们弄清楚他们处于什么位置，比如，我作为一个数学人是谁？我如何将我的数字信心水平与我实际拥有的能力水平相匹配，这真的会有帮助。这意味着如果你需要帮助，你会寻求帮助，也许你会更努力
if you really have the skill, but you're just not confident about it. Something else. People can become more numerate. It takes practice. There's not a lot of research on this. So a little bit, this has to be taken with a little bit of a grain of salt. But people can take math classes. That would be the hardest thing. And that kind of practice would likely matter. We had done some research that suggests that just practicing in an easier way can help. You don't have to practice with particularly difficult math. But if you practice with simple math, like adding and subtracting numbers, practice by estimating the answers. You first have to estimate the answer before you see it
如果你真的有那种技能，但你只是对它没有信心。还有别的事。人们可以变得更识数。这需要练习。关于这一点没有太多的研究。所以这一点必须稍微持保留态度。但人们可以参加数学课。那将是最困难的事情。而且那种练习很可能会产生影响。我们进行了一些研究，表明仅仅以一种更容易的方式练习也会有帮助。你不必用特别困难的数学来练习。但如果你用简单的数学练习，比如加减数字，通过估算答案来练习。你必须先估算答案，然后才能看到它
because you have to get feedback about whether you're right or wrong so that you can actually learn. It turns out the learning requires knowing what you've done correctly and what you've done incorrectly so you can do better the next time. But our research shows that even doing this in about six sessions of about 30 to 45 minutes, if I remember correctly, this can improve people's objective numeracy. and it actually did improve the consistency with which people perceived risks.
因为你必须得到关于你是对还是错的反馈，这样你才能真正学习。事实证明，学习需要知道你做对了什么以及做错了什么，这样你下次才能做得更好。但我们的研究表明，即使在大约六次、每次 30 到 45 分钟的练习中，如果我没记错的话，这可以提高人们的客观识数能力。而且它实际上确实提高了人们感知风险的一致性。
So we know that that helps. We need more research on it. But again, it is hard to manipulate numeracy among adults. Another thing, and then just sort of a long series of studies in my lab and others, suggests that that idea of developing good number habits may be important. And so people should pay attention to the numbers in their lives. Try not just to read over them. develop good number habits by spending more time, by transforming and calculating numbers, by comparing
所以我们知道这有帮助。我们需要对此进行更多的研究。但同样，很难操纵成年人的识数能力。另一件事，然后只是我实验室和其他实验室的一系列研究表明，培养良好的数字习惯这个想法可能很重要。所以人们应该注意生活中的数字。尽量不要只是读过它们。通过花更多时间、通过转换和计算数字、通过比较
numbers. Sometimes that makes all the difference. If you know how likely some treatment is to help you, take a look at some other plausible treatment and compare it and see which one might actually offer you more benefit. That'll help you derive more affective or emotional meaning from the numbers. And then the last thing kind of gets back to that technology question that you mentioned, Kim. And the idea is to advocate for yourself if you don't understand some number. Or if the person didn't provide a number and you feel like it might be helpful,
数字来培养良好的数字习惯。有时这会产生所有的不同。如果你知道某种治疗对你有帮助的可能性，看看其他一些合理的治疗方法并进行比较，看看哪一种可能实际上为你提供更多的好处。这将帮助你从数字中获得更多的情感或情绪意义。然后最后一件事有点回到你提到的那个技术问题，金。这个想法是，如果你不理解某个数字，就为你自己辩护。或者如果那个人没有提供数字，而你觉得它可能有帮助，
you can ask like a physician, how statistically likely is something? What is the probability of something happening? Or if you're given too many options or too much information, you can ask a professional to simplify, the information. So that to whatever is the most important information in their view. And by doing that, people actually will understand more. Sometimes less can be more. What about the people who need to convey numerical information, whether that's doctors talking to patients or maybe journalists explaining economic data, scientists who are trying to explain climate risk? How can they help people better understand the numbers they're putting out there so that we can make better decisions?
你可以问像医生那样，某件事在统计学上有多大可能？某事发生的概率是多少？或者如果你被给予太多的选择或太多的信息，你可以要求专业人士简化信息。所以，以他们看来最重要的信息为准。通过这样做，人们实际上会理解更多。有时少即是多。那么那些需要传达数字信息的人呢，无论是医生与病人交谈，还是记者解释经济数据，科学家试图解释气候风险？他们如何帮助人们更好地理解他们发布的数据，以便我们能够做出更好的决策？
Yeah, so there's a series of recommendations that I would make from my lab and communicators will often make. The first one is to have a communication goal. And that sounds kind of silly in some ways, but I've been in all kinds of interviews where I'm sitting in like on a doctor's visit with a patient or a physical therapist's appointment with parents of a child who's not doing well. And they often go in with this like mound of information that they pick up and they put down in front of the patient. And without really thinking about what does this person really need to know? How can I facilitate how they understand? If you sit back and think first about what a communication goal is, that means that you can actually strategically choose what information to show. And then think about, again, strategically, how might I show it?
是的，我的实验室和传播者们通常会提出一系列建议。第一点是设定沟通目标。这听起来可能有点傻，但我参加过各种各样的访谈，比如坐在医生诊室里看医生与病人交流，或者物理治疗师与病情不佳的孩子家长沟通。他们往往带着一大堆信息，一股脑儿地抛给病人，却并没有真正思考：这个人到底需要知道什么？我该如何促进他们的理解？如果你先退一步，思考沟通目标是什么，这意味着你可以战略性地选择展示哪些信息。然后再思考，同样是战略性地，我该如何展示这些信息？
And then we get to the kinds of research that I do, which has to do with, how do you format information? What kinds of information might you show? And one of the first recommendations that I always have is to communicate with numbers, not only words. So there's this funny thing that happens where people often prefer communicating with verbal terms like common and unlikely, but people actually kind of prefer getting numbers. And not only do they prefer getting numbers, but they also better understand risks and they can react appropriately when numbers are discussed, so long as the numbers aren't too difficult. You don't want to provide too many numbers. But what ends up happening when you provide numeric information is not only do
接下来我们谈谈我的研究领域，即如何格式化信息？你应该展示什么样的信息？我总是提出的第一个建议是：用数字沟通，而不仅仅是文字。有一个有趣的现象：人们通常更喜欢用“常见”、“不太可能”等口头词汇进行交流，但实际上人们更倾向于接收数字。他们不仅更喜欢数字，而且在讨论数字时，他们能更好地理解风险并做出适当的反应，只要数字不太复杂。你不想提供太多的数字。但当你提供数字信息时，会发生什么呢？
people understand better, which helps to support informed consent processes and other things like that. But just the mere presence of numbers seems to increase people's trust in the message and their perceptions of the expertise of the messenger. And on social media, for example, people are more likely to share numbers that include numeric information compared to the exact same message minus the numbers. So that's one thing. Communicate with numbers, but you do have to make those numbers more manageable. And there's sort of two ways to do this. One is to provide less information. So remember that communication goal. You want to provide information that helps to meet the goal, but not more information than that if you can help it. Because more information means,
人们不仅理解得更好，这有助于支持知情同意过程及类似事项。而且，仅仅是数字的存在，似乎就能增加人们对信息的信任，以及对信息发布者专业性的认可。例如，在社交媒体上，与完全相同但没有数字的信息相比，人们更有可能分享包含数字信息的内容。所以这是一点：用数字沟通，但你必须让这些数字更易于管理。有两种方法可以做到这一点。一种是提供更少的信息。所以记住那个沟通目标。你要提供有助于实现目标的信息，但如果可以的话，不要提供超过这些的信息。因为信息越多，
just a greater likelihood of losing somebody along the way. With less information, people do understand more. So you want to avoid cognitive overload. The other part of making numbers more manageable is do the math for people. We often give people information where they have to do a little bit of math and you lose so many people along the way. Another thing would be to make numbers more meaningful, you can provide context like we talked about this a little bit before too.
人们在过程中迷失的可能性就越大。信息越少，人们理解得越多。所以你要避免认知过载。让数字更易于管理的另一部分是：替人们做数学题。我们经常给人们提供需要他们自己做一点数学运算的信息，结果你在过程中会失去很多人。另一件事是让数字更有意义，你可以提供背景信息，就像我们之前稍微讨论过的那样。
if you talk about 93% of patients will survive from treatment A, maybe you also want to give them a comparison. This is compared to 99% of people who would survive with treatment B. And by having that comparison, people can draw their own meaning. What are some of the other things? This goes back to more general communication advice from the literature. We often want to inform people and we want to help them better understand a situation that they're in so that they can make their own decisions. And you don't want to overwhelm them like we were saying. But in the end, we also often want to tell people what are the possible solutions here? And you want those solutions to be something that people think will work and that they're confident that they themselves can do. And so that kind of furnishing
如果你说93%的患者能从治疗A中存活下来，也许你还想给他们一个对比。比如，这与治疗B中99%的存活率相比如何。通过这种对比，人们可以得出自己的理解。还有哪些其他建议？这回到了文献中更通用的沟通建议。我们通常希望告知人们，并帮助他们更好地理解所处的状况，以便他们能做出自己的决定。你不想像我们刚才说的那样让他们不知所措。但最终，我们通常也想告诉人们：这里有哪些可能的解决方案？你希望这些解决方案是人们认为有效，并且他们有信心自己能做到的。
of feasible solutions is really important. And we think about that a lot when it comes to communicating about hazards. So if you're communicating about earthquakes, for example, in the Pacific Northwest, you want to make sure not only that you can about the risk of an earthquake and what might happen, what the likelihood might be, what those consequences might be. But you also want to tell people, what can I do about it? What can I do? What can I do that will work? And what can I do that I'm confident that I can actually do? And so those are kind of some of the general things that I think about when it comes to communicating numbers, but also going beyond numbers to the idea that we're communicating to help people's lives. So you want to go beyond the numbers to things like furnishing solutions that are doable for people.
因此，提供可行的解决方案非常重要。在沟通危险时，我们经常考虑这一点。例如，如果你在太平洋西北地区沟通地震风险，你不仅要确保人们了解地震的风险、可能发生的情况、可能性以及后果，还要告诉人们：我能为此做些什么？我能做什么？我能做什么有效的事情？我能做什么我有信心真正做到的事情？所以，这些是我在沟通数字时考虑的一些通用原则，同时也超越了数字本身，即我们沟通是为了改善人们的生活。因此，你要超越数字，提供人们切实可行的解决方案。
Well, that makes perfect sense. So what are the big questions you still want to answer? What are you working on right now? Oh, you know, we are still looking a bit at the mere presence of numbers. You know, I have to admit, I come from an engineering background originally. And so I'm a little bit of a geek when it comes to numbers. And so I just, I personally just find it fascinating that the mere presence of numbers can change how much people trust, how much people think someone's a number. expert. And I'm curious about why. So we're sort of delving into that a bit more. We just in the past probably a year or two have been looking more into how can we communicate more effectively about hazards that people face. And those are the earthquakes and the wildfires. And the reason for that is
嗯，这很有道理。那么你还想回答哪些重大问题？你现在正在研究什么？哦，你知道，我们仍在研究数字的存在感。你知道，我必须承认，我最初是工程背景出身。所以当涉及到数字时，我有点极客。我个人觉得，仅仅是数字的存在就能改变人们的信任程度，以及人们认为某人是专家的程度，这非常迷人。我很好奇为什么。所以我们正在深入研究这一点。在过去的一两年里，我们更多地研究了如何更有效地沟通人们面临的危险。这些危险包括地震和野火。原因在于
I love doing psychological science. I love the brain candy of psychological science. It's just really interesting to find out how the human mind works. But I also wanted to make a difference. And so I want to make a difference in people's lives and hopefully, you know, help people to better understand something that's important to them and that will help, just help improve the quality of their life. And so that's why we've gone into some of the hazards research, because I think that's important. Well, Dr. Peters, I want to thank you for joining me today. It's been very enlightening. It has been very fun. Thank you again, Kim. It's been a pleasure. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org
我热爱心理科学。我喜欢心理科学带来的思维乐趣。发现人类思维如何运作真的非常有趣。但我也想有所作为。我想改变人们的生活，希望能够帮助人们更好地理解对他们重要的事情，从而改善他们的生活质量。这就是我们进行一些危险研究的原因，因为我认为这很重要。好的，彼得斯博士，感谢您今天加入我们。这非常有启发性。非常有趣。再次感谢你，金。这是我的荣幸。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目，
or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Relax and let Ralph's delivery handle your grocery shopping this week.
或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何您获取播客的地方收听。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请关注我们并留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。感谢您收听美国心理学会的节目。我是金·米尔斯。放松一下，让 Ralph's 的配送服务来处理您本周的杂货采购吧。
We start with only the freshest. items, then review your list and carefully choose each one. Then we pack it all up and deliver it in as little as 30 minutes so you can feel confident it's what you ordered. Fresh groceries, your way, with Ralph's delivery and pickup. And right now, you can save $20 on your first delivery or pickup order. Ralph's, fresh for everyone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们只从最新鲜的商品开始，然后查看您的清单并仔细挑选每一件。接着我们打包好，并在短短30分钟内送达，让您确信这就是您订购的商品。新鲜杂货，随心所欲，尽在 Ralph's 配送与自提服务。现在，您的首次配送或自提订单可节省20美元。Ralph's，为每个人提供新鲜。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。